on l'a décryptage avec vous tatiana
castillet va jean bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre notre invitation vous êtes
chercheur à l'ifri directrice de centre
russie nouveaux états indépendants
auteur par ailleurs notamment de la
russie de poutine en 100 questions alors
c'est vrai que depuis hier il ya un peu
de son de cloche chez les russes qui
d'un côté
et c'est de démontrer leur bonne foi en
bombardant d'image la télévision
notamment en montrant ses chars ses
blindés ces soldats qui amorce à un
retrait puis l'autre côté on a les
européens qui sont quand même très
sceptique ce matin encore cela von der
leyen
réaffirmé sa volonté d' activer des
sanctions en cas de en cas d'invasion
russe qui dit vrai dans l'histoire
aujourd'hui c'est difficile de trancher
un c'est pas si difficile que ça en fait
depuis le début de la crise je passe
pour une optimiste en disant deux choses
d'une part le scénario de la guerre
c'est sous lui ou la russie a plus à
perdre et nous - à gagner et la deuxième
chose la meilleure sortie de crise pour
tout le monde y compris pour la russie
c'est l'entrée dans les négociations
quand c'était le gars à l ucad pendant
la guerre froide de longues négociations
ou la russie en fait mais au centre ses
propres préoccupations sécuritaires ça
on peut développer des arguments des uns
et des autres pourquoi pourquoi je
l'affirmé ces choses là ce qui est clair
aujourd'hui le problème n'est pas réglé
pour la russie il n'est pas réglé parce
que l'occident ne peux pas donner de
garantie de non adhésion à l'otan de
l'ukraine et il ya sur certaines choses
sur certaines préoccupations sécurité
russes on ne peut pas non plus répondre
le donner la suite positive mais il y a
en même temps des choses sur lesquelles
on peut négocier nous sommes l'avait si
tout se passe bien d'un long processus
de négociations dans lequel il y aura
des périodes de tension donc c'est pour
ça qu'il faut être extrêmement prudent
il ya eu ces tensions la russie a obtenu
des choses il va à nouveau recourir à la
menace militaire si besoin de renforcer
ses positions dans la négociation ce que
voulait dire c'est qu'on reste de revoir
peut-être très prochainement ses camions
mais aller dans l'autre sens on en a
déjà vu au mois d'avril on en a vus
depuis le mois de novembre
on peut de nouveau en avoir et la russie
avaient fait preuve qu'elle était
capable d'utiliser l'armé militaire
d'une manière ciblée limité mais
néanmoins capable elle en a fait la
preuve en syrie aussi dans le no mas en
2014 ce que vous êtes en train de dire
finalement aujourd'hui c'est que les
russes ont obtenu ce qu'ils réclament
est finalement négocié discuté au début
de ce qu'ils ont réclamées et à certains
points cruciaux sur lequel ils peuvent
pas avoir gain de cause mais ils ont
obtenu la prise en compte de certains de
leurs intérêts qu'ils affirment
finalement je dirais même de petits
boris eltsine est encore plus fortement
avec les dix meilleures poutines avec
son discours à munich en 2007 avec la
proposition de dmitri medvedev sur
l'architecturé de sécurité européenne en
2008 à l'époque on avait balayé solana
revers de la main aujourd'hui on a
écouté parce qu il y avait cette menace
qu'on a cru imminente qui pesait sur
l'europe alors écoutez et dire qu'on va
discuter et négocier c'est une chose
aller au delà sans mais c'en est une
autre on a bien vu sur la question de
l'otan qui a un point cher pour les
russes n'y aura pas de compromis
possible là dessus bah écoute et après
c'est une ses larmes la diplomatie de
trouver les formulations peut-être qu'il
ya aujourd'hui des formules qui ne sont
pas sur la table mais sur lequel on
pourrait tomber d'accord mais en effet
le ne semble cruciale pour le tancer la
politique de portes ouvertes et c'est
aussi la charte de paris qui dit que
chaque pays a le droit de choisir son
système d'alliance militaire et son site
le système pour assurer sa propre
sécurité et pour les russes c'est plutôt
le principe de sécurité indivisible
qu'il met en avant c'est à dire la
sécurité des uns peut affecter la
sécurité des autres en clair l'adhésion
à l'otan de l'ukraine peut affecter la
sécurité de douleur mais si c'est ce que
les autorités russes disent depuis le
début de cette crise on a beaucoup vu
les européens les européens temporisé
essaie de calmer le jeu al'inverse des
américains
de l'huile sur le feu des américains qui
vont discuter aussi avec les russes
c'est une une victoire pour vladimir
poutine très honnêtement je pense qu'on
a vécu un vrai moment de guerre
d'information à grande échelle qui sur
certains aspects peu comparable avec la
crise des missiles à cuba en
1962 et c'est vrai que vous dites vous
êtes en train de dire qu'on vient de
vivre un moment de l'histoire ces
dernières semaines c'est un élément
absolument tout à fait à mon nom je
pense qu'un palier en point de
basculement dans six épreuves où vous
avez cru qu'il était possible que ça
bascule que ça dérape comme certains le
disent l invasion comme je disais tout
au début non je ne croyais pas depuis le
début et je détaille et j'avais des
arguments pour développer ça et je
voyais aussi cette divergence d'analysé
entre les américains les russes les
ukrainiens les europe 1 finalement les
plus calmes dans l'histoire était et
ukrainiens et qui en veulent en quelque
sorte aux américains d'avoir monté si
haut les enchères notamment avec
l'évacuation des diplomates etc et je
crois qu on évalue pas aujourd'hui la le
préjudice que les états unis sous bei
den ont porté à leur propre image dans
une certaine mesure je dirais que biden
a nui plus avec opus avec le retrait de
l'afghanistan et avec le comportement
dans cette crise ukrainienne à l'image
des états unis en tant qu'allié pliable
encore plus que tranquille on fait trop
les américains je pense qu'ils en ont
fait trop tout à fait les ukrainiens
étaient censés être avec pour tout vous
dire avec gulliver crown correspondant à
quai dans cette édition je crois que ça
ne sera pas possible on retrouvera un
peu plus tard on était censé évoquer
cette journée de l'unité que célébré
aujourd'hui les ukrainiens cette date
qui avait été avancée par certains comme
la date de l'invasion au des russes les
russes qui raillent d'ailleurs les
ukrainiens à ce sujet aujourd'hui a une
fois de plus sur les 10 meilleures
poutines le maître des horloges qui a
imposé son agenda qui a ridiculisé en
quelque sorte les américains avant tout
en montrant que ovale à la veille de la
date qui était annoncé comme la date de
l'invasion finalement il annonce une
amorce encore une fois il faut être
prudent mais une amorce de l' escalade
finalement ils maîtrisent ils manipulent
les opinions publiques il nous il faut
vraiment qu'on progresse sur la
connaissance de la russie et les
mécaniques de prise de décision des
positions russes etc avant de rentrer
dans ce jeu-là de manipulation de
l'information trouvait justement que les
européens n'ont pas été suffisamment en
retrait je le disais ils ont beaucoup
temporisé essaie de calmer le jeu en
disant attendait voilà on est on est au
début de négociations les américains a
testé un dès le départ que l'armée russe
allait envahir l'est de l'europe ce que
semblait pas vraiment croire bruxelles
j'ai beaucoup plus de reproche à faire
aux américains cause europe 1 a au
contraire les europe 1 je trouve que ils
ont fait ce qu'ils devaient faire avec
cet activisme diplomatique les
tentatives de calmer le jeu de tous les
côtés ils n'ont pas cédé à la panique à
la différence des états unis je crois
qu'ils avaient seulement quelques
ambassades qui ont suivi les états unis
dans le mouvement de retrait de leur
personnel diplomatique et cetera la
france n'a pas suivi par exemple donc il
y avait une bonne mesure en contraire
pour les pays européens où il y avait de
tout une ouverture au dialogue la
fermeté les manifestations de l'unité et
on a bien vu emmanuel macron faire le
nécessaire en tant que pays président de
l'union européenne dans cette affaire
qu'est-ce qu'il faut qu'ils verrouillent
comme comme points stratégiques les
européens les ministres de la défense
vont se retrouver samedi à munich 1
ministres du g7 justement pour faire le
point sur cette crise qu'est-ce-qui
qu'est ce qu'il leur manque sur quoi
elle pêche aujourd'hui je pense qu'il
faut vraiment être très précis sur la
lecture des intentions de la russie est
analysée autant le mouvement des troupes
sur le terrain je pense qu'on s'est
vraiment concentré sur le volet
militaire pour dire est-ce que aulas et
gallas et fusant sceau des troupes pour
attaquer et c'est je crois que c'était
le volet géopolitique qu'il fallait
privilégier dans l'analyse pour
comprendre ce que la russie à perdre et
à gagner et ce qu'elle cherche vraiment
l'affluence rue ce sera peut-être ma
dernière question on parle de l'est de
l'europe on parle aussi beaucoup du mali
ces dernières heures le retrait des
français de la force takouba européenne
là où
la présence russe se renforce avec
notamment cette milice wagner c'est tout
un autre sujet sur lequel on peut faire
des 'amis à se désagréger russe mais
s'inscrit aussi dans la stratégie russe
qui à la fois la récupération de
l'influent sont quelque peu perdu après
la chute de l'urss en afrique il y a des
intérêts militaires stratégiques mais
aussi économique et financier qui se
mêlent dans ce retour de la russie vers
l'afrique et pied en fait le joker dans
la poche c'est que ça embête aussi les
occidentaux et ça fait un levier de
pression supplémentaire sur certains
gouvernements dans l'union et lyonnais
notamment la france